prendre la haute technologie et dans
l'isoloir aujourd'hui les électeurs
d'issy les moulineaux expérimente le
vote du futur
c'est à l'aide de cartes à puce qu'ils
vont faire leur choix karine dufour marx
à dino un vote d'une simplicité
enfantine
fini les bulletins des enveloppes en
papier à son arrivée dans le bureau
chaque électeur reçoit une carte à puce
électronique un peu comme une carte
téléphonique dans l'isoloir un
ordinateur affiche le nom des différents
candidats à l'aide d'un crayon optique
il ne vous reste plus qu'à faire votre
choix qui est mise en mémoire dernière
opération glisser la carte dans l'urne
électronique
le veau sauce immédiatement enregistrées
et stockées sur un logiciel à la fin de
la journée il faut 30 secondes à
l'ordinateur pour afficher des résultats
étendus à toute la france ce système
permettrait de connaître les scores
définitifs en 30 minutes très simple
plus facile avec le stylo pauvreté
pour le de prendre le petit papier de
mettre l'enveloppent blessures
ce permis est déjà utilisée en belgique
et en norvège ce système n'est toujours
pas homologué en france
demain les électeurs voteront donc deux
fois le système permet ce que les
suisses appellent les votations c'est à
dire les scrutins locaux à partir de
problèmes ponctuels comme un sens unique
comme l'implantation d'une grande
surface
l'augmentation des impôts des sujets
tout à fait locaux l'utiliser dans les
rites et dans lé cadre de la démocratie
pour que les choses soient moins
coûteuse plus efficace oui substituer à
l'acte électoral un acte anodin fait
chez soi non les cartes à puce feront
donc une entrée discrète dans l'isoloir
pour que tous les français votre part
électronique
il en coûterait 2 milliards de francs à
l'état